un exploit historique le club des
clayes-sous-bois participera au 6e tour
de la coupe gambardella la coupe de
france des moins de 19 ans les
cliniciens qui évolue en deuxième
division de district ont réussi à faire
tomber clichy sur seine au stade et
beltramini une équipe qui évolue deux
divisions au dessus des yvelinois le
score 3 2 ans on est bien rentré dedans
on a dominé en première période on a mis
le but qu'il fallait mettre ensuite en
deuxième ça a été plus dur
ils sont revenus il voulait revenir dans
le match mon a tenu avec le troisième
but en fin de match on a tué le match
on se tuera les uns pour les autres
c'est comme ça je coupe le match en 2
première mi temps et gagne 2 0 2e
mi-temps et m'ont satisfait en mettant
leur dernier but qui fait important des
habitants et qui nous donne un score
total de 3 ans donc entièrement
satisfait de cette équipe qui veut et
qui a envie d'aller le plus loin
possible et continuer l aventure comme
toujours
et grâce à cette victoire les clients
sont devenus le petit poucet français de
l'épreuve ils peuvent rencontrer au
prochain tour une équipe située en
dehors de la région ile de france le
tirage au sort sera effectué ce mercredi
16 novembre au siège de la fédération
française à paris les quais sous bois ne
veulent pas encore se projeter sur leurs
futurs adversaires les plus impossibles
à le plus haut possible prendre du
plaisir d'aller le plus haut possible
un centre de formation ce serait bien
aussi peu importe ils veulent voyager
donc ça peut être loin et qu'on peut
aller jouer loin serait pas ça leur fera
plaisir je te reprendre des journaux
travail la vie on va le faire pour eux
le 6e tour de la coupe gambardella est
programmée le week-end des 3 et 4
décembre